gardez dans la rue jean son attention
est tout le problème c'est les grandes
surfaces ya trop de concentration de
personnes dans les grandes surfaces
c'est surtout ça le problème je pense
pas que ce soit il faut rouvrir les
universités il faut que les jeunes
puissent avoir un avenir et avoir des
cours actuellement c'est eux qui sont
les plus pénalisés par des mesures et il
y en a plein qui tombe dans l'extrême
pauvreté car il se passe nourrir qui
sont complètement en isolement trouve ça
dramatique
je pense que les personnes âgées elles
font attention malheureusement il ya
effectivement des personnes qui sont à
risque ici qu'elle prenne soin d'elle et
qu'elle passe de deux dans plus
attention mais la majorité des gens même
ici conscient du problème de l'impact
que ça dans leur vie donc ils sont pas
prêts à voir un troisième confinement
c'est sûr parce que j'en vois beaucoup
qui met pas le mas correctement et c'est
le plus important je pense que c'est le
masque
moi je dirais qu'il ya 50 50
malheureusement mais quand même on fait
ce qu'on peut
ce que je vois dans la rue actuellement
depuis quelques temps je les trouve
assez responsable ce que tout le monde
fait quand même les efforts de porter le
masque de dire que la salle et ils sont
contents de ce qui se passe je pense de
moins en moins je pense que
psychologiquement ça commence à
a touché pas mal de personnes non non en
fait on n'est pas responsable du tout je
pense vraiment ras-le-bol
on arrive au peut-être au troisième
confinement et c'est un peu trop je
comprends pas pourquoi on ferme encore
les restos les bas et qu'il ya autant de
monde dans les métros et dans les rues
surtout plus dans les centres
commerciaux
c'est pas normal faudrait réagir
autrement qu'en soit on confine tout le
monde soit en route ou quoi bah je sais
pas je ne sais pas quoi vous dire mais
oui je pense que oui elle est
suffisamment responsable je pense que un
troisième confinement personne n'a
vraiment envie
[Musique]
j'ai pas ça me paraît juste changé moi à
titre personnel je n'ai pas envie c'est
pour ça que je vous réponds ça je ne
sais pas c'est des gens assis
responsables les français quand il va
être responsable regarde et qu'on aille
le premier confinement il y avait
personne le deuxième compliment
c'était un peu moins parce que avec les
heures mais je pense qu'ils sont assez
responsables et frontier pour à 8,1 des
compliments je pense que les français
sont parfaitement responsable après le
confinement c'est une autre décision qui
n'a rien à voir avec la responsabilité
des français les français dès qu'on leur
a donné des masques il est soumis on est
tous éloignés dont je pense que les
français sont très responsables alors je
suis assez raisonnable pas 100% et après
il ya j'étais étonné de voir dans paris
tous les gens qui prenaient des verts
aux terrasses de café il me semble que
ça c'est pas très raisonnable éviter de
voir dix mille personnes de alors moi je
dis qu'on peut sortir il faut continuer
à sortir dans la nature et jeudi
laissez-nous la nature voilà
laissez-nous la nature peut être moins
de consommation ferment quelques
magasins medicine où la nature pour le
bien-être de tous
effectivement on pourrait se passer d'un
troisième confinement
mettant tous responsables et encombrant
les lieux de culture notamment de
manière à ce qu'on puisse appliquer un
protocole strict et ça me semble tout à
fait possible mais moins infantilisant